the Clark County School District is
mourning the loss of a teacher who was a
real Trailblazer when it came to music
Albert Avia had a passion for music and
education he helped launch ccsd's
Mariachi Azul and taught at Fremont
Middle School and tonight Christian
Garcia spoke to his widow about the
music teacher and how she's now working
to fulfill a dream
it's been weeks since Albert Avila
passed away his wife Julie Gathering her
strength to share his story after a
sudden stomach pain forced the couple to
rush to the hospital ultimately losing
his life during an intestinal rupture
some days are good
actually I should say some moments are
good
um
most moments aren't Avila says the 39
year old school teacher was a staple
with the Clark County School District
helping launch Mariachi education across
the state of Nevada he worked really
hard a lot of the time to make sure that
mariachi music wasn't just looked at as
a novelty that it it had the same faces
as Jazz as band as orchestras choir
eight news now highlighting his work
during this year's Hispanic heritage
celebration I love it I love hearing it
I love seeing the passion that they grow
for as members of the Mariachi Azul from
Fremont Middle School showed off their
skills foreign
expressing our culture today the
mariachi music education program is the
largest in the country the group was
recently selected to represent Las Vegas
at the Midwest clinic conference in
Chicago a dream Avila was hoping to
perform at to help grow the music
program and show other band directors
Orchestra choir directors that they
couldn't create this program to connect
to those students
public funeral service schedule for
November 12th at 8 in the morning at St
Christopher Catholic Church which is in
North Las Vegas now the students are
raising money for that music conference
in Chicago they have set up a donation
page and we have posted it so you can
share it on 8newsnow.com